en ce moment tous les quatre matins on a
l'impression qu'on va sauter voilà
comment un conseiller ministériel résume
la nervosité ambiante au sein de
l'exécutif
à la veille du premier remaniement
d'ampleur de l'air macron l'inquiétude
est palpable les dossiers à l'arrêt qui
va rester qui va se voir promu et qui va
perdre son poste dans les semaines à
venir emmanuel macron décidera des
grandes orientations de la fin de son
mandat à l'occasion pour le chef de
l'état de renverser la table
selon les confidences de ses proches le
premier ministre edouard philippe
pourrait être la première victime de
cette volonté de changement
ce proche d'alain juppé marqué à la
droite est inflexible sur la réforme des
retraites pourrait être incompatible
avec une deuxième partie de quinquennat
qu emmanuel macron voudrait plus sociale
et écologique
edouard philippe actuellement lice pour
la mairie du havre où il est crédité de
53% des intentions de vote pourrait
décider de se consacrer à sa ville s'il
venait à remporter le scrutin
les prétendants ne manquent pas pour le
remplacer à matignon bruno le maire à sa
droite ou encore jean yves le drian sur
sa gauche
le ministre de l'économie jure pourtant
sur toutes les antennes que le job ne
l'intéressent pas depuis qu une note
confidentielle de gilles legendre chef
des députés lrm adressé à l'elysée et
dévoilé par l'hebdomadaire marianne
proposait de faire de lui le prochain
premier ministre
parmi ceux dont le poste est menacé on
peut citer la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud ou encore elisabeth
bornes la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
mais c'est surtout parmi les ministres
dits régaliens que le bât blesse
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
semble condamné certains proches du
président l'accusent d'avoir cassé le
lien avec les professions du droit
idem pour son collègue de l'intérieur
christophe castaner plus que jamais
fragilisé par le mouvement contre les
violences policières et le rejet qu'il
inspire à ses troupes une autre proche
du président sur la sellette six bêtes
ndiaye porte-parole du gouvernement qui
a enchaîné déclarations hasardeuses et
quoique surtout pendant la crise du
coronavirus et qui pourrait également
faire les frais d'un remaniement
parmi ceux qui devraient rester chacun
avance ses pions comme la très
médiatique secrétaire d'état à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
marlène schiappa qui déclare vouloir
faire
plus à l'heure actuelle les intentions
du chef de l'état reste nimbée de
mystère
le remaniement et la question du futur
premier ministre seront un indicateur
politique fort de cette deuxième phase
du quinquennat